God is almost done picking his 2016
fantasy Ohio Governor John Kasich
continues to hit as interest in running
for president but says he's waiting on a
sign from God before making the call
Kasich who is eyeing a slot in the GOP
primaries opened up on NBC's Meet the
Press reasoning my family is a
consideration but the most important
thing is what does the world want me to
do with my life however Kasich isn't
just going to wait around for a sign
he's been active on the trail just in
case as one of the five Republican
governors considering a bid for the
presidential nomination including scott
walker chris Christie and rich Snyder
okay so it seems to me that what a crazy
person would do is wait for a sign from
God to do something often murderers
isn't that what a lot of murderers do
they get a sign from a dog which is just
God's fell backwards or something like
that to do say but that's what this man
is actually waiting to be is waiting for
God to go you should price today but
again but nobody no he's not and that's
what's that's what's almost worse like
if you were waiting for God to give him
aside like Sarah Palin or Ted Cruz who I
think may be legitimately think they get
signs from God and some others then I
would be more willing it wouldn't be
quite as cynical it would just be crazy
John Kasich is by all accounts not even
in the totally lunatic realm of the
Republican Party but they all have to be
if they're running for president so he
has to pretend this guy funny has to
pretend even and dismisses his family my
I'd be like dad [ __ ] off no ask me for
some sign and then going through but no
I'm still gonna visit Iowa New Hampshire
just in case God hasn't made up his mind
yet I mean it's but he's pandering yes
you cannot win unless you pan so is that
everything that's wrong with politics
right there he has to get through a
primary which is basically just an
exercise and who's the craziest and he
has to do that just so that he can then
bring all those positions back at some
level right this is the classic
comeuppance moment in the horror film
where the mad scientists that built this
giant dangerous stupid stomping monster
is working the remote control and it's
coming out of my back and the remote
doesn't work anymore
right now it's coming for him yeah back
I tell you he can't control so that's
what the monsters coming for him at the
thing that was supposed to make life
easier for them by breeding this
generation of remote controllable people
now is backfiring because of all the
dogma edict with those people they all
want him to look like he's standing by
yeah we got the legit people interesting
people who seemed interesting in that
party are instantly no longer
interesting when they run for president
Rand Paul yet was causing at least some
progressives at some point to be like ha
if I had a gun to my head and had to
vote for Republican i think i could
maybe vote for that guy not now no
increase in defend the things that made
him interesting he's completely
abandoned yeah I would refer Rand Paul
might be last on my list now and then a
guy like Marco Rubio who comes out is a
he's young like Obama a new senator like
Obama and then has an actual interesting
idea about immigration the brakes with
his party look I ate a good one the
other guys yeah now he just seems dumb
so what role i get it were la elitists
here so it seemed like on send bad least
we have one la elitist here where work
you know we're at but yeah um but that
we are here so we can watch this stuff
and think it's completely bonkers but
obviously Kasich is talking to someone
he's either talking to the people that
believe that he's talking about orie to
some people that want to hear it as
you're saying earlier how many of those
people actually exist anymore it's art
it's hard to tell enough to make a
difference in Republican primaries I
mean you know we've seen I mean that was
a you know that was a those it was an
audience that cheered into the death
penalty that cheered that Buddha gay
soldier yeah these are back these guys
are bad Americans they're bad for the
country they do not reflect the ideas
that made this country great remember
that everyone who's gonna run who who
would be asked who would say like no
God's not asking me to run I'm practical
I want to reduce spending I want to have
the budget balanced it's a big thing for
Kasich constitutional amendment balance
the budget who is gonna say the words
Jon Huntsman like hey don't a guy tried
that uh and he was a joke and he never
got more than two percent of the vote
and now he's not even in the party John
Hussman real quick when they were due
when he ran last
and I was tweeting about all the the
debates and everything the only joke i
could make about him was that he seemed
like he was being held hostage by crazy
people because that's because he was
actually saying and shouldn't have been
like a cold walk he was actually a
decent guy but he's not running
unfortunately anyway what do you think
do these guys just have to pander is our
system so broken does God have a place
in politics let us know in the comments
right down below